what up guys there's only a few days
left to get your copy of shady agents go
to the Kickstarter link below if you get
the black and gold box there's a bunch
of unlockables and one of them is a
not-safe-for-work
question pack so make sure you get the
black and gold box in a few days left go
there and support get your own copy
because after the Kickstarter is over
you're not gonna be able to get it
anymore this week we got escape room
blunder youngest billionaire and idiot
customers I already know the middle one
the first one all right so for the first
story this burglar called the cops after
he got stuck in an escape room after
breaking it like a literal escape route
why would he break into an escape room
that is dolly who's he gonna steal like
a bunch of LED lights and [ __ ] like yeah
what what what was the purpose doesn't
he know you have to be smart to get out
of it I never get out of there you
literally you're not surprised do not
read the sign I [ __ ] hate escape room
[ __ ] [ __ ] boring
it's like you're inside of a puzzle wait
a minute hey guess what early 8th though
yeah well guess what
I don't like puzzles and as a kid I
[ __ ] hated puzzles and so now I have
to actually be inside of a puzzle
no thank you what was that anyone's
smart in your team because that's what I
realize if you have a team of dumb [ __ ]
you get really frustrated because no one
because you're supposed to attack
different parts of the room and you come
together yeah and you don't want to go
another person is just like just blue
and red I don't know what to do you know
that's the reason why I don't want to go
to escape room
why because I'm that guy oh I'm not I'm
not worried that there's a lot of dumb
people in there I could go with only
dumb people and myself we're all dumb
together then I would have way more fun
but you're a smart guy oh you just feel
left out puzzles no I'm not I don't I
don't because I'm not patient with
puzzles UI files real
Yeah right that's exactly one is I don't
give a [ __ ] everyone's like excited like
oh like we're in one I was in one like
in the mountain it's like role-playing
though it is like role-playing now I was
in one yeah we're in like [ __ ] Julian
or whatever and we're what is it Big
Bear Big Bear and and they're they play
this thing first where it's like oh
there's an avalanche outside and like
they play speakers and [ __ ] and I'm just
like I don't give a [ __ ] do we did one
in Malaysia it was a [ __ ] serial
killers room and those dead bodies
everywhere and they had music playing
that that was like scary as [ __ ] and
every time somebody would scream like
heartbeat yeah yeah and it would be
great we hear people like like screaming
getting chopped up and I'd be like
what's that
[ __ ] we're gonna die it so like we're
like I'm like adrenaline is pumping at
me like a theater and see me and David
here's me and David in the haunted house
you know what it'd be fun though four
shots before we go in Matt oh that's far
that's what you guys need that blood you
need you guys are alcoholics four shots
is not alcoholic you need to drink
floors on your shot each that's not all
you guys I'm thinking about what if I
get kidnapped and this happens
thank God I trained why do they want to
kidnap you though because I'm [ __ ]
known dude take them to a medieval
castle
thank God he trained in a medieval
castle but see that's my role playing
you want that Moreau Blane medieval
[ __ ] they have those Novak but
that's what I'm talking about medieval
times I get to sit drink beer eat a
[ __ ] turkey let you don't want to
work I get to scream at all the nights
you could throw food and then they read
a [ __ ] you're not supposed to throw
food anything they throw that thing down
dude I don't think they have a net they
have a net that goes down when you start
throwing food at that dude I was happily
the red knight so [ __ ] hard when we
were at baby blue times was that another
red knight know that so we were on teams
right and we were the white knight team
or whatever the [ __ ] and there was a red
knight and there's like Blue Knight in a
yellow light washer and I was screaming
at this one that I was like tough
thought thought the red Knight [ __ ] the
red
[ __ ] [ __ ] - and eventually like my
team actually my team got mixed like
word towards the end they put teams
together became friends with the same
team but it's like what I always wanted
about chuck-e-cheese right
like you can't heckle the chuck-e-cheese
guys bunch of kids there but at medieval
time you're goddamn right you that's
your job that's your whole job [ __ ] up
we couldn't believe it I reserve watch
my YouTube buddies and they were all
just like you you [ __ ] [ __ ] so he
was in the business for 35 minutes so
when he was trying to get in he damaged
a doorknob so badly that he couldn't get
out and that's why he got stuck so he
ended up calling the cops but though
you're like a rock like a different
address eventually he did end up getting
out and by the time he got out through
the back door a police officer was there
to arrest him
isn't it funny how he called the cops
and not the locksmith I want to call a
lock or a friend on our home he stole a
TV in her he stole her cell phone and a
TV remote TV remote TV he stole the
remote
for personal use maybe there's a
universal remote maybe we'll give him
that yeah maybe maybe it's 100 all
universal my bestest saddest thing
that's like the homeless guy that tries
to sell you a TV room out on the streets
has it ever happened to you
no a couple of times did is I it's like
what are the the DirecTV ones that comes
with the thing is I yeah it's the
DirecTV what happened twice try to sell
me a DirecTV remote yeah he drank a beer
and he ate a burrito do you have a
picture of this door it'd be fun if you
could you could have just kicked that
open oh and he was just like oh dude
that's this is like Walmart right where
you take a candy bar and the guy gets
arrested like please you let this guy go
take some remote and eats a burrito he's
putting unless is like a steel door yeah
that it's really hard
you don't mean yeah but if it's a
regular oz door you could kick it down
or if it's a glass door throw like a can
of soda through it and you can just walk
right through it to go back to you
that's like a liquor store like you know
a glass door always not that easy do you
remember that guy they trying to break
it with a dolly
no he broke in through the liquor store
through the roof and he crashed yeah
yeah yeah yeah tried it he had a dolly
and he swung at the glass door it
wouldn't break what is that's really was
it bullet probably maybe or it's like
shatterproof but it just wouldn't break
yeah for our next story
Kylie Jenner is on the cover of Fords
and they're saying that by the time
she's 21 she's set to be the youngest
ever self-made billionaire oh wow she's
so self-made self-made something made
hold on a second dude that's a little
wild twin she's not even 21 yet - she
comes from she's from a third-generation
family dynasty dog yeah self-made is a
little a little little push there yeah
are they rich already will her dad yeah
both dads put the Kardashian dad
Kardashian Robert Kardashian was like
the kingmaker of this whole plan right
he was the famous lawyer of defendant of
multimillionaires right and then the
reality TV show even made more million
than that yeah she grew up in like on
the reality TV show and they live in
Calabasas momager Kris Jenner is like a
super cuz I guess I can see why they
would say self-made because even if
you're multi-millionaire you're still
really far from being a billionaire so
even Michael Jackson never became a
billionaire right so he's been touring
since he was like five I can see where
they're coming from like if your parents
are billionaires and then you became a
billionaire that's not self-made but if
you're even if you're a hundred
millionaire you're technically a peasant
in a billionaires eyes so that's still
like rags to riches from that
perspective I think the technical term
for a self-made is if it's not through
inheritance yeah well so for in her case
they're saying that her money so she
started her Kylie cosmetics and she's
they back in 2014 like it's tough yeah
it's good we tried it uh yeah I have I
mean the tint everything's good like
honest we like it yeah
not shitty I never tried it I didn't
know she did existed until recently so
back in 2014 she started this company
with 250,000 dollars of her own money
that she made through modeling and
endorsement deals and that's how she
started like the first batch of her lip
kits and so now they're saying that
she's her birthday is in August so by
the time she hits 21 that she's probably
gonna be a billionaire because right now
she's at nine hundred million dollars
Wow okay but how do I [ __ ] on this
because I don't want to give her chronic
yeah that's crazy yeah well I mean you
know that's the same thing with Paris
Hilton because of the Hilton name people
kept saying like yeah man she's got it
but then she made a lot of her wealth
through you know media and from her own
actions and from her own line lines of
dude she absorbed the Hilton name
because like when you look at the Hilton
buildings now you think you think of
parrot yeah
nothing Archibald Hilton or whatever the
[ __ ] it was and even she's not building
anything that's crazy
Paris how can I be such a strong brand
where I could just sell whatever the
[ __ ] I want you have to make sacrifices
and be a little soulless because the
thing that they do is like wow I don't
know I don't think I could do that but
then when you're a billionaire you could
buy your soul back in Africa I mean
money the charity's is starting a
[ __ ] foundation with your face on it
and chant and be like hey we're here in
Africa I'm like handing out [ __ ] I guess
I always do that [ __ ] I get Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation do you know how
many [ __ ] companies that Microsoft
destroyed like on their way Microsoft
was stolen in the first place well right
exactly and they would I mean they would
do some crazy [ __ ] back in the day like
like all the antitrust [ __ ] they used to
do they even LA in violation I lost you
and then later on bills Bill Gates is
just like hey like malaria like we can
get rid of that and that's what you do
like you buy your soul back so you
destroy the world and then you come back
and say all right time to clean it up
you knew you [ __ ] over a lot of plenty
of people but then you like help better
by helping the less fortunate
okay people or I just wish I was rich
vessel me too when everyone who's
watching this is like you are rich [ __ ]
you
you're [ __ ] rich I'm rich in
friendship is what I am okay Tesla I
have rich in friendship in love he
spends all his money on cars oh yeah yep
did I just [ __ ] roll in that [ __ ]
please we closed a bad deep a [ __ ] with
that no no it's wild it I'm rich in
[ __ ] you when I see you in a Honda
Element I'm like there's a guy who
spends all his money on cars rich is all
like relevant to what were your rat two
though because in the billionaires
they're like on a way different level
from hundred millionaires like
billionaires they own their yachts and
planes and then like millionaires they
like you ever gone Zillow like this
thing searching around I look for the
most expensive house in LA that [ __ ] was
like 50 million there's pads that are
70,000
dollars a month for rent 70 G's a month
70 G's a month to rent and there's some
guy out there that's painting like
nothing wow what the don't even want
that good I just want to look at a menu
at a restaurant and not look at the
number oh yeah you know I'm saying dude
roll with me McDonald's I'll splurge on
you just [ __ ] throwing cheeseburgers
at my face oh I'll give you a kid kid
menu stuff all the time with the [ __ ]
adult they get you [ __ ] but then some
people watching this right now and
they're going I can't do that in
McDonald see Bart you are rich see I
remember not being able to do that at
McDonald's yeah yeah I'll say this in
college
yeah I've been calling that bless you
still I used to every Taco Tuesday at
Del Taco we used to go there because it
was three tacos for a dollar and there's
two chickens soft tacos for a dollar and
that's when we would splurge that's when
I felt like a [ __ ] king but now I go
to Del Taco and I just get diarrhea you
know how I used to bulk in college I
would go to Carlos jr. and get the spicy
chicken get two of them it's only a
dollar each and they're 300 calories
apiece so that's 600 calories for only
two bucks how much do people need to
know chickens call it depends on comfort
what what quantifies comfort cuz like
upper middle class right my wife now for
her she's like I need a house with a
pair you and all [ __ ] me should never
got the ads house it ruined everything I
know now an aunt has a [ __ ] tight
pool I know that's what I'm saying was
fantastic it was great projector now I
see outdoor projector and see now my
wife wants all that [ __ ] what am i doing
this is the problem dude I just want
lights in the bathtub you could do that
under even care where I am I just need
to have my computer be able to set up
and [ __ ] and then I have a door door is
still a maybe it's a screen door it's
not good yeah I don't give a [ __ ] I used
to live in Koreatown dude back in the
like 2000 mid 2000s and it wasn't great
but I didn't give a [ __ ] it was tight
for last story this video went viral
with the caption welcome to Mesquite
Texas Oh muskie yes here we go
they gotta I think they got saw that
this was so cool here we go this is
inspiring oh my god that poor baby's
ears the [ __ ] you staring at baby when's
the baby gonna talk so what exactly
happened I'm confused about the net card
thing there's like three people yelling
at her she was supposed to get a refund
but she didn't get I think we should
laugh she did get a refund but she was
just upset so what happened she's
explaining a teen you keep in Genosha
she's just jumping in the middle I need
to know what happened to beginning the
whole point
they were just being rude as customers
and this really struck a chord with
everyone who's ever dealt with customers
from mesquite no no okay yeah and this
is not a Sears edit series I mean it
just goes to show that Sears is on its
last [ __ ] legs do they have you have
you seen Sears like have you driven by
Sears is pretty sad I went into a Sears
like maybe last year I have to buy at
Tobiah I ran out of it was like a socket
I needed to get a certain size socket I
got it again oh yeah that's done you
know what like when you get like towards
a job that you that you're about to quit
you start to really not give a [ __ ] oh
yeah
like when I was at the Men's Wearhouse
probably the most rudest the rudest
thing I've ever done well first of all
she was a [ __ ] and she deserved it but
basically her son had he's huge right we
have up to like four XL best he could
have fit into it also far beyond like a
4 XL vest you have to get a vest that
just straps with the strap in the back
all right
now this you get two vests together he
understood he was completely okay with
it I told him to I was like hey we we
can't get you one with the back just
because it doesn't fit we're gonna need
the last a band yeah that's exactly what
it is though really so he was okay now I
was set on two chairs so we fitted we
fit him and we would actually got him a
tuxedo that fit him and he had his
problem whatever he comes to return a
mamasan Bengals the vest doesn't have a
back I want my money back for the whole
tuxedo and then well we explained to him
that he can't fit into she goes I don't
care I want my money back
she starts screaming at me right and so
I got so mad and mighty she had a cane
she's also huge too and she has a lazy
eye I was like listen man unless you
look me straight in the eye I cannot
give you a refund I decide there wait
did she try to will will
I need the deal if I'm like she's like
you said you think you're so funny I go
absolutely not but this is very
disrespectful that you won't look you in
the eye when you're talking to me you're
like and not to mention if I can show
you right now miss if you see here I'm
putting on the vest of you got your son
and it wraps around me twice yeah I'm I
literally told her to I was like you're
embarrassing your son right now because
there's like a kid like all these kids
from high school trying to get their
tuxedo for their prom
yeah she's making a scene because he's
so fat he can't fit into it yeah I'm
like you're embarrassing your son you
need to chill out and her son her son's
like mortified
you know help like dude bro just walk
out
[ __ ] the best mom was just bleep come on
you're just talking about a full effect
like show up you know yeah the lady was
a shitty surface tumors yeah I deal with
a lot of that [ __ ] she was like me the
unknown [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]